[Music]
morning
[Music]
friends
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
today's feast goes back a long way in
the church Mary was first declared
Mother of God the Council of Ephesus in
431
the actual origins of this Feast are
obscure but we know around 500 A.D the
church celebrated a day of the theotokus
or the god-bearer either before or after
Christmas
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the sweeters
[Music]
the Secretary of State Cardinal parallel
now approaching the Altar and venerating
the altar he will be our celebrant at
the altar today
we know that in the Roman Church that a
feast was celebrated for Mary's birthday
on the 1st of January
overshadowed by the feasts of the
enunciation and the Assumption
and January 1st eventually became the
Octave of Christmas the day on which the
baby Jesus received his name
[Music]
[Music]
generating an image of our Lady here
especially for yesterday and today
our lady Del card meaning from avellino
in Italy
[Music]
eventually A Feast for Mary's Divine
motherhood began in Portugal and in
51 Pope Benedict the 14th allowed the
churches in Portugal to celebrate her
Divine motherhood on the Sun the first
Sunday in May and the importance of
Devotion to our lady in May
it was then extended to other countries
and in 1914 was established on October
11th becoming a universal feast in 1931
we prepare ourselves now to begin Holy
Mass
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
please sir
[Music]
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
listening
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
and we play Pregame
is
foreign
first reading this morning comes from
the Old Testament book of numbers
it will be proclaimed in French
Israel
the Lord spoke to Moses
say this to Aaron and his sons
the sons of Israel you shall say to them
may the Lord blessed
may the Lord
shine on you and be gracious to you
[Music]
may the Lord uncover his faith to you
and bring you peace
This Is How They are to call down my
name on the sons of Israel and I will
bless them
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and the response to a responsible son oh
God be gracious and bless us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
please
our second reading today comes from the
letter of Saint Paul to the to the
Galatians
they're using for your self-feel when
you see the time again
the spirit
that cries
and if God has made you son then he has
made you heir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they can be
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chanted by the choir at various times in
the past and in various different ways
God spoke to our ancestors through the
prophets
but in our own time the last days
spoken to us through his son
we prepare ourselves
secure the proclamation of today's
Gospel from The Gospel According to Luke
Dominos
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
glorification
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
perception
[Music]
[Music]
ebook of the gospels now being placed in
a place of honor on a
Throne that was used during the second
Vatican Council just above the image of
the Child Jesus allowing us to conquer
ties a bit
mystery we celebrate in these days of
Christmas when the word
second person of the Blessed Trinity who
originally spoke to us through the word
has now become incarnate taking on our
own
blood
and we now prepare ourselves to hear
Pope Francis homily for this solemnity
of Mary Mother of God
of God
this is the joyful acclimation of the
Holy people of God echoing in the
streets of Ephesus in the year 431.
when the council fathers proclaimed Mary
the Mother of God
is a fundamental doctrine of Faith
but above all it is a marvelous fact
and is this bound forever to our
Humanity like a child to its mother to
the point that our humanity is his
humanity and
consoling children
at the most recent Council would be
celebrated here in St Peter's stated
that by his Incarnation the Son of God
has in a certain way United himself
with a human mind
of the Virgin Mary he truly became one
of us like us in all things exceptions
embracing it truly
truly
brothers and sisters
because in
Christ's chest a heart of Flesh
continues to beat
that beats for each and every one of
them
holy mother of God
many books and weighty tomes have been
written about this title of our Lady
yeah
through this simple and familiar prayer
that accompanies the rhythm of our days
our greatest desperations
Hail Mary
after a few phrases taken from the word
of God the second part of the prayer
continues holy Mary Mother of God
often repeated throughout the day
to our lives and to our history
do this invocation the mother of God
always responds she hears our petition
she's holding her son in her arms
she blesses us and brings us the tender
love of God
in a word
beginning of this year we need Hope
just like the Earth
let us pray to our mother in a special
way for her sons and daughters who are
suffering and no longer have the
strength to pray and foreign
Regina
the blessing we heard in the first
reading
may the Lord lift up his countenance
upon you and give you money
God peace wants to enter into our homes
our hearts and our world
what do we need to do to receive that
peace
let us be guided by the people we meet
in today's Gospel you were the first to
see the mother and child the Shepherds
they were poor people and perhaps
and that night they were working
not to learn it or the powerful they
were the first to recognize
who became poor and
Shepherds did things that are simple but
are not always easy
they went and they saw
to go and to see
two actions
the gospel tells us
they do not wait around it was nice they
had their flocks to keep and naturally
they were weird
held off until sunrise in order to go
and see a child
they went with hates
when important things are concerned we
need to react promptly and not wait
for the grace of the spirit Brooks
encountered the Messiah the one awaited
for centuries the one that so many
others
brothers and sisters if we are to
welcome God and His peace we cannot
stand around complacently waiting for
things to get better
we need to get up
recognize the moments of Grace set out
take a risk
we need to risk
today at the beginning of the year
rather than standing around thinking and
hoping that things will change we should
instead ask ourselves this year where do
I want to do
who is it that I can help
that paralyzes our hearts and the
temptation to waste time glued to a
keyboard in front of a computer screen
the shepherds are summoning
set out
they're inviting us to set aside many of
our routines
in order to open ourselves to the new
things of God which are found in the
humility of service in the courage of
caring for others
[Music]
Brothers and Sisters Let's imitate the
Shepherds
when they arrived the gospel tells us
it then says that after having seen the
child they set out filled with wonder to
tell others about Jesus glorifying and
praising God for everything they had
heard
the important thing was
important is to see to look around like
the Shepherds
before the child resting in his mother's
arms to say nothing to ask nothing to do
nothing simply to look on in Silence
the tender and comforting love of God
made man
among the new things we'd like to do and
experience let
me keep some time to see to open our
eyes to keep them open for what really
matters to God and our brothers and
sisters
do we have the courage to
Witnesses
at the mystery or are we attracted more
to the seduction of the world
the amazement of an encounter with God
gives you peace
to talk with our children to ask them
about how they really are and not simply
about their studies and how good it is
to take time to listen to the elderly to
our grandfathers and grandmothers
in order to remember the deeper meaning
of Our Lives
let us ask ourselves
true whether we are capable of seeing
the people next door the people who live
in the same building the people we meet
every day on the streets
and Sisters Let's imitate the Shepherds
let's learn to see
our hearts by sea let's learn to see
foreign
foreign
holy mother of God
holy mother of God
holy mother of God
we allow these words to sink into our
hearts
we allow this beautiful image of our
Lady to help unveil the mystery we
celebrate today
that we've just reflected on with our
Holy Father
and we prepare ourselves to
enter into a moment of Prayer
with all of our brothers and sisters
gathered here in
Saint Peter's Basilica today
with about
5 000 people
we will soon hear invocations
various languages of the world
lifting up one
voice
praying for the needs of the church
and the world today as we celebrate the
solemnity of Mary the Mother of God
which also coincides with the 56th world
day of peace
and now we profess our faith
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the greatest
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for Glory
[Music]
it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
blessings
of the Holy Spirit fills the universe
with his merciful love
[Music]
and we pray in Chinese
path
[Music]
[Music]
remember O Lord Pope Francis and all our
Bishops illuminated by the light of
Bethlehem
may they be credible Witnesses of your
merciful countenance for the building up
of a Christian Community founded on love
[Music]
we pray in Ukrainian
s
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
singer
from
tradition in Germany where children
dressed as the three kings carrying a
star go caroling from house to house
as the gifts are presented we hear the
beautiful chanto Monument
which is the fourth responsory and
Christmas morning prayer one of the most
beautiful texts of the Liturgy
a great mystery and wonderful Sacrament
that animals should see the newborn Lord
lying in a Manger blessed is the Virgin
whose womb was made meet
to Bear our Lord Jesus Christ
[Music]
and now a family presenting
the gifts that will
soon become the body and blood of Our
Lord here as the holy sacrifice of the
mass is renewed on this altar
[Music]
and another family with a little girl
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Glory
[Music]
days
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
mystery of Christ once again become
becoming present in these created Gifts
of bread and wine which have been
offered by the community
idea of
the faithful people are also incense the
beautiful statue the beautiful image of
our Lady
that has been placed here on the altar
helping us
enter into the mystery
an image that allows us to see our lady
very colorfully dressed
allowing us to see how a community has
understood that she is near to them
[Music]
Devotion to Our Lady of Carmine
coming from the community of aviviano
near Potenza in Italy
and back to the 16th century
it's identified with the dates of 8th
September 1694 when a violent earthquake
devastated an area in near there but the
villagers of aviliano there were no
victims
they attributed it to her intercession
and from then on other
other
ways that they believe our lady has
protected them
a young girl who fell into
a dream due to a violent storm
was
unharmed that took place in 1719
or calling on her after
severe drought in 1844 rain came
they've often invoked her for other
natural calamities it's a way for us to
remember that our lady is close
she hears our prayer that she continues
interceding as our mother and as the
mother of God
is
foreign
because
it is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Padre
is
ilio is
Jesus Christ
so that from the rising of the sun to
its setting a pure City delicious
[Music]
which will be given up for you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
do this in memory of me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
made the sacrifice
foreign
customers
on YouTube
[Music]
Gloria
[Music]
territory
[Music]
and we are now being invited to pray the
Lord's Prayer
obedience
[Music]
We are following us
[Music]
and he needed
[Music]
Lord we pray foreign
[Music]
thank
you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
offers
peace to the con celebrants Cardinal
Michael cherny prefect of the dicastery
for promoting integral human development
in Archbishop Paul Richard Gallagher
secretary for relations with States
[Music]
we've lost
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and we too can say oh Lord I am not
worthy that you should enter under my
roof
but only say the word and my soul shall
be healed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
songs
choir chant
chantantifan for book
it Zachariah
Joyce oh daughter Zion lift up praise
daughter Jerusalem behold your king will
come the Holy One and savior of the
world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
by Pope Paul VI in 1967
being inspired by the encyclical love
John the 23rd pachem in Terrace
[Music]
first world day was celebrated in 1968.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as with every World they have peace our
Holy Father has released a message this
year reflecting on a verse from the
letter of Saint Paul to the
Thessalonians
now concerning the times and the seasons
brothers and sisters you do not need to
have anything written to you for you
yourselves know very well that the day
of the Lord will come like a thief in
the night
our Holy Father tells us that with these
words we too are asked to remain
steadfast with our hearts and feet
firmly planted and our gaze fixed on the
world around us and on the events of
history as we await the Lord's return
he says when tragic events seem to
overwhelm our lives and we feel plunged
into a dark and difficult Maelstrom of
Injustice and suffering we too are
called to keep our hearts open to Hope
and to trust in God
who makes himself present
who accompanies us with his tenderness
sustains us in our weariness and above
all guides our paths
he also reflects on the covid-19 crisis
and the current War
we now prepare to conclude our Mass
and we pray
he is
we pray that it may lead us to it in a
life for we Rejoice to proclaim the
Blessed of a Virgin Mary Mother of your
son and mother of the church
all right
foreign
omnipotent
but
I feel you
feel yourself
descendants
[Music]
first
[Music]
year
[Music]
and we now have the alma redemptoris
mater Marion antifung
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER Gate of Heaven Star of the Sea assist
your people who have fallen yet strive
to rise again
to the wonderment of nature you bore
your creator yet remained a virgin after
as before
Gabriel's joyful greeting have pity on
us poor sinners
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hear the strain strains of adeste
Fidelis
we see the procession now making its way
away from the altar we see the beautiful
[ __ ] scene set up in St Peter's Basilica
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
for the solemnity of Mary the Mother of
God
it's the Vatican news reporter Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter friends for
the summer of this literature
as well as other coverage
you can also find many things in related
to open emergency Benedicts
we will be back shortly with the live
broadcast of the recitation of the
angels with Pope Francis on the first
day of 2023 dedicated to Mary Mother of
God and the world day of peace
[Music]
as we leave you with these beautiful
images of Pope Francis venerating the
Child Jesus We wish all of you a blessed
and happy New Year we thank you for
joining us and a special thanks to our
in studio audio technician Adriano
Vitali and our audio coordinator
Thaddeus Jones as well as to our Media
Partners Catholic TV Catholic faith
Network Shalom World television networks
USA
EWTN Salt and Light media Shalom TV
India at madarshan TV radio Maria
Philippines radio Maria England and
luminous radio we hope to see you back
with us shortly for the Angeles
Jesus Christus
praise to Jesus Christ
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]